hello everyone i'm alan welcome to my
channel doesn't even sound like a word
anymore
today we are playing the new among us
map using the crew link mod meaning you
can hear people when they're near you
i get very lost but i do some good
detective work it's a good time but i
did also want to let you guys know that
this video is sponsored by
the nevers so we will hear more from
them somewhere in the middle of the
video
enjoy main hall let's go i'm going to
learn this map any minute now i swear
hello
hey mary just learning the uh-huh
oh yeah just learning the layout saya
yeah
brilliant does anyone want to shower
with me would you like to yeah i'll
shower with you
cool oh i'm actually just hitting the
shower with a hammer
oh i don't actually have this task i've
never had it
that's strange that's what it is yeah
absolutely no sex and hammer
yep you just kind of tapped the top but
i thought that i was supposed to take a
shower
yeah maybe it's real sad am i being
marinated by the two of you what's
happening
okay cool hey mary i trust you this time
and i'm scared of these other people
here
okay what are we doing wrong you're just
circling a bit much
you know okay then i'll walk away i'm
sorry i just wanted to i didn't even get
to talk to you at all last time alana
and it made me sad
that is fair i just want yeah okay
okay oh comps
oh oh oh
okay so i think that was bria
i'm gonna say it was brilliant
so i walked like up through the library
and then out the left whoever was behind
me i think it might have been mary and
then there was
maude was dead and i i saw blue
down the bottom which means that bria
was right next to it
really you just tried to bail how to get
to the other side that's it
that's it while the dead bodies i mean
we're all trying to figure that out it's
the worst i don't know
i'll be right back okay so that no one
can even just fake
say they don't know how the gap works
the bridge is there it's on one side or
the other you can't
call it over to the other side it's just
whatever side it's on
you can then use it to get to this only
one person could take it at a time well
that's what's been struggling
anyway it was brilliant
um so i was doing the toilet plunger and
taye
also said she was doing the toilet
plunger and it took her like three
seconds to do which was
i'm gonna try to watch the movie my
friend
maybe they were small poops bob maybe
they were small poops
i'm very i know you eat a lot of fiber
of alana defending tay
right now well that's just for a joke
currently defending small poops
yeah i'm just you know making hot goofs
out here it was bria who killed mort
no me neither i skipped i was like all
right pretty confident about bria
walking away from the dead body
but uh we'll take a step to kill me last
time keep an eye out let's vote for john
next
uh oh oh the comms are still no those
ones don't work we've established that
they do not work
we have to walk to the comms
okay uh
wha this some kind of cabinet okay
yep look at me go okay
oh is that supposed to be locked
what's happened these are supposed to be
locked
no what i don't know
okay well i've just wasted a lot of time
so
that's not ideal i don't love that for
me or maybe they were on a timeline
beautiful pro gamer [ __ ] right there
okay meeting room hey mary
because this is where i sold brio
[ __ ] damn it well yeah so she
definitely killed him
she's trying to vent away yeah she 100
killed okay
it is time to talk about the nevers on
hbo and this
incredibly cool box that they sent me i
actually did an unboxing on my instagram
stories if you want to check that out
but this thing is wild they they sent me
this
box that i couldn't open that came with
this like instruction guide and all
these clues
we have like i had to use this to find
one of the clues
okay we have located the elephant i have
to poke a screwdriver inside of the hole
and then open a latch
uh this is all very cool like just
we have all these different kinds of tea
have you ever wanted chamomile infused
sugar cubes because you got them now
how about vanilla infused sugar cubes
bam i can't shoot this bit with my
webcam because the box is too big and
heavy to move but i can't shoot it with
my phone
it's so so so cool like
oh my but essentially if you didn't know
the nevers is an epic science fiction
drama about a gang of victorian women
known as the touch to find themselves
with unusual abilities relentless
enemies
and a mission that might change the
world it's a really story-driven sci-fi
show
and the box is based on one character
called penance
who has this ability where she can sense
energy so maybe she can sense where
electricity might be
and that allows her to invent future
tech stuff
which i guess is how we got you know
this neat light bulb
but yeah you can check out the new hp
original series the nevers
and a huge thanks to hbo and hbo max for
sending me this
incredible kit and thanks to hendrix gin
for the partnership it's
so cool oh no kai who saw the body
cool is that it yeah i was trying what
else did you see
i was trying to see if anybody else was
around like an immediate but no one else
was around so
there's an event literally in that room
to the left right
yeah left and south of us yeah and it
could have just killed and
yeah i was hoping i'd catch him before
they did that listen i'm information
just back on team bria because i went to
the area where i found maude's dead body
and the only
place that you can go you can't leave
from which is where brio was sitting
nobody came out the door it was directly
down
yes like you're going back and
inspecting the area
i was trying to get through some kind of
maze and i got lost
and then i was like oh i'm back here now
and then i checked it out
there's a vent down there my guess is
she was about to vent but we caught her
too soon
i had the i had the mentality to vent
it's
it's that's what i was trying to do yes
because if you walked back out you would
have walked into a room with three
people after you just killed mort
so
yeah and that's where bria was
the only other person there and nobody
came out of the room that's what i'm
saying
we could 50 50 alana and bria
so was i and everyone was ready to throw
me out the window
but i say 50 50 and i'm i'm a bad guy
but but i also have
married a voucher me as having walked in
behind me too
in a room where bria was
i don't know what i did that was
suspicious they told me
and like mary and someone else in there
is very aggressive on me
you killed someone okay if you ain't
murdering people i'm not gonna be
aggressive about it
if you murder someone in front of me i
might be suspicious
what i'm gonna do stupid [ __ ] safe
again okay let's go
i am confident about bria but maybe
they'll murder me this time i didn't do
anything
two five
four okay well we've done it oh my god
look at me go i if you say this ain't
[ __ ] now i became so pro at this game
uh
oh oh someone else fixed it okay
disregard how do i get
so the gap is on the other side and
there's nothing i can do about it
so i have to go the whole way [ __ ]
down here are you
what is this [ __ ]
no okay beautiful
um okay john i think you're innocent so
i i have to get to the meeting room but
because the gaps on the wrong side
i have to go through the engine room up
the break and then around right is that
correct
yeah yeah this way that's where i gotta
go to my god
i got two in the meeting room hang on
should we do the crash course first
though
no because we can there'll be a there'll
be a gap a vehicle near this side
oh hi over there oh there's a lot of
people out here all right oh okay
there's no one on the other side you
said you said mary you said mary went
over there
there you go we got it okay up here for
some reason i thought we could go up
from there
but we can't oh this is the meeting room
great okay
john did not leave me perfect wires
perfect wires
four three eight three one three
eight two oh five
okay i'm going to the vault
let's go let's do it vault times this is
just directly through here
i'm learning oh a dead body
somebody killed mary no
she's in the vault oh no john is a
counter i was just with mary and she
opened a door for me because i can't
[ __ ] do the swipe thing and then
i walked away and she's already gone did
you see anyone else
no i mean yes uh
tay tay was over there like you guys
were all went up and it was me
tay and mary down below down below
yeah like not in the meeting room yeah
not in the meeting room
oh yeah yeah no this why did you go wait
sarah was about to be
right no i wasn't i tried to go up and
then i
because i thought there was like a way
over and then i went back down wait then
who was up there with alana and me
know this i think it was me no jobus
yeah okay so then yeah it was it was a
sarah tay and barb party down there
okay but i listened you heard me i was
doing left reactor and they
did and then i said mary did the right
one and then i just left after that
i'm like in the kitchen right now i
haven't seen bart
go back i just left everybody up there
and then wait where has barb been
i've been everywhere baby
[Laughter]
loading my guns i'm plunging
every opportunity to kill me so many
times and i don't think it's gonna be
do you john do you think we should maybe
skip
yeah i think it's sarah i think we still
have two left
oh yeah of course i mean unless alana
was completely wrong about bria
no i'm like super confident i mean i
could have been but if i was i have a
lot of apologies to issue to bria
if i was wrong i got i got makeup i got
to send her some flowers
i think i really gotta apologize for
that one
i don't think so though i'm skipping
because i don't know
i'm thinking look i'm gonna say right
now i'm thinking sarah
but we'll see hey
what yeah those two votes count
what did he say i wanted to go wherever
john was so chat let me just give you
hot tips
the reason that i think that it's sarah
it totally is sarah um is because of the
comment she made and i say this is
someone who does not know sarah
i could be completely wrong she made a
comment
um when i was talking about going back
to where bria was
where she was like what are you a
detective i don't think anyone who's
innocent would do that
and then all the other stuff lines are
up as well but based on that
the particular thing she chose to say in
that instance
that's what i'm thinking hey what's
happening
on this side that's weird so i'm
confident about bria
she was below where john was it doesn't
she had to be she was the only one in
the room it had to be her you know
um hello
okay i'm cool with nervous i think we're
fine
um john hello
i'm scared
i can get killed here what's the task is
it this one again
no can i what what task is it what what
am i oh it is this
oh well that's cute this airship's
pretty
pretty chill i feel like i have a great
time in this particular airship
situation hello
i really don't want to die if i nope oh
baby cool vent cool [ __ ] vent sarah
okay okay let's just go to the [ __ ]
meeting room let's just get i saw sarah
event i saw sarah event i'm trying to go
to the meeting room to report it i saw
sarah vent everyone she vented
we're going to report sarah it's done
do they have to do the crash course
first will it not work no it works
oh i can't be i'm just staying away i'm
staying away
you guys please fix this you gotta do it
okay boom
yeah all righty our work here is done
hey sarah it didn't mean for me to see
that did ya
that was your talk that was the accident
that you did that right in front of me
wasn't it
sarah just keeps getting caught in the
merry christmas oh i'm so
mad i just want to be a murderer can't
you just let me kill some people
she wasn't even killing anyone john she
just vented
invented no there was a dead body i had
killed tater tot and then i
just didn't die so are you gonna kill me
again on that platform sarah be honest
i wasn't kidding on the platform but i
saw you and i was like oh i should chase
after barbara kittler it would be so
great
i felt like it was too mean beautiful
look very nice
i was very happy when i saw it i was
like i suspected it yes
you know i'll vote for myself as well
like i didn't see it it was bria right i
wasn't just being a huge [ __ ]
oh thank god
[Music]
[Laughter]
sometimes i get too spicy for my own
good for my own self
hey
a nice one look at the killer i cannot
figure out where it's going
you can't get caught doing the killing
that's that's the whole that's the whole
thing
yeah that was a good tip about the whole
what are you a detective
i heard that whole analysis yeah yeah
i'm really i'm really specific about
how i analyze people in this camera you
know but only when she's not
thousand batman statues and she thinks
she's the best